thank you for calling in to the David
Pakman show
please do not use speakerphone have your
question ready and listen for David to
call out your area code okay Larry your
connection is is one of the worst we've
had
you're not talking into the phone
through like a crinkled piece of paper
are you all right so Eric listen
something's going on with your phone
every third word it sounds like you're
underwater is that is there anything we
might be able to do about them great and
we're not on speakerphone are we no okay
and whatever is on in the background if
you are able to turn it down it would be
really great yes yeah all right well
what's going on
uh I actually don't have a phone number
from New Jersey but I currently live in
Philadelphia Pennsylvania
all right that's still allowed hey I'm
surprised you still remember me we have
caller ID so I have copious notes about
you Nathan listen I'm gonna let you go
because it does sound like you're
underwater and I don't know what's
causing that but I do appreciate the
phone call and I look forward to
welcoming you back on the program once
again in the future no idea her phone or
bluetooth because your connection is
abhorrent Jean let me interrupt for a
second I don't know what you're talking
about and it sounds like you're pressing
I'm curious are you doing something else
in addition to doing this call right now
great your audio level is going up and
down like crazy so if you can do
something to just even it out that would
be really great all right can you hear
me better yeah what I'm curious what did
you do that we can just all of a sudden
hear you so well Wow but you bring up a
good point Keith and there it sounds
like buttons are being pressed and
there's a weird audio thing so I'm gonna
let you go but very well-made point yes
it sounds like you both on speaker and
at a bowling alley and you hear me at
all
everything okay Brad it sounds like
you're doing kind of tool work yes
without roaches everywhere man huh good
I'm glad to get you back waiting till
he's got the roaches
okay Brad deal with the roaches in
callback certainly an unusual phone call
David you know what you're annoying I'm
hanging up on you okay
thank you right cool oh thank you thank
you all right
Elan you might have us muted because we
can't hear you but you are on if you
unmute we might be able to hear you
otherwise I'll have to move on hello
it's me that's you hey Carlton now let
me ask you what kind of device are we on
are we on some kind of headset or
speakerphone gotcha okay it's it's
pretty atrocious but we'll try to deal
with it what's what's your question
today I couldn't hear your name and we
can barely hear you so let's see what we
can do about either your connection or
your phone or something okay that's a
little better what was your name last
call sorry hold on hold on we can we've
got you we've got your volume at the max
and I can still barely hear you you said
something about a Jimmy Dore call no I I
just wanted to apologize yes it is where
you coming from
well actually the phone number is
located in Poland but I'm actually
calling from Ukraine how dare you call
from a different place than your phone
number that is horrible a contacts asset
okay hold on a second Donna let me let
me back up because you're shot out of a
cannon today did you say this is Austin
from Boston no Oscar from okay good
Oscar if we're on any kind of device
that might make it harder for me to hear
you please get off of that device
because we've got you maxed out and your
level is very very low you got better
that is much better yeah
7:32 historically has been a tough area
code for us so we'll see who this is it
can be it can be great or not so great
who's there from seven three two hey
David this is Danny from I'm actually in
San Diego California but my area coats
from New Jersey all right then I'm sure
you won't be a problem today that's you
yeah and what's going
with your phone I don't know it sounds
like you're talking through a pillow you
you've now given me like twelve
different sets of requirements and ifs
ands and buts like I I I would rethink
this and call back okay I got a lot of
people holding but what you're saying is
not making sense I disagree with the
premise and I don't mind okay can you
hear me alright you know I can hear you
extremely well anyway here's someone who
called in I guess trying to just spite
me about being on speakerphone David of
mine Baker okay start so you've got a
terrible signal I didn't hear your name
did you say it was Barry yeah Barry you
hear me better we're not on speaker or
Bluetooth are we oh we're on Bluetooth
we are okay yes let's - let's not do the
Bluetooth thing today please Barry
bluetooth thank you I can hear you so
well yeah who's this okay hold on a
second so you sound like you're
underwater and I didn't catch your name
and I can barely hear you so let's let's
talk through it what's your name okay
very good
tell me once more what your question is
and it please if we run speaker or
Bluetooth take us off because you sound
like you're underwater
just one quick what do you think of me
do you like me sorry what do I think of
what hmm what do I think of what mmm mmm
what do I think of memes yeah okay so
let me see if I understand John and in
the meantime if you do have a son
speaker or using Bluetooth please take
us yeah I have headphones so let me take
me okay yeah and you know we've we've
updated that message when you call in
telling people don't do this stuff
because we can't hear a word you're
saying
alright Andy we can barely hear you and
please tell me we're not on speakerphone
hello hello hello can you hear me yeah
you cut out there sorry I must be
problem I thought so
what I was gonna
you're cutting out again obviously you
won okay and with that pop we we lost
Ken absolutely all right I'm trying to
have a conversation with you but you're
just not allowing me to and I am out of
time so I'm gonna let you go I I do
appreciate the call but I would love to
be able to have more of a conversation
with you yes we've got you turned up as
loud as you'll go and I can still barely
hear you so what what might we be able
to do that that is better yes awesome
great we're having somewhat of a bad
connection so I'm glad you got through
and if you can get to an area where your
signal is better that would be great but
what's on your mind today good good
I don't know what's going on in the
background if you're bowling or
something but if we are on speaker
please do take us off and you can go
right sounds crazy in there
oh using a headset well let's just if
you can tell us the game that would be
great if we're on some kind of speaker
please do take us off how are you good
are we we're not on speakerphone are we
no oh boy all right go ahead
all right Rome thank you please let's
see if next time we can get a better
connection because you I love what
you're saying but I just am having a
hard time hearing a lot of it and that's
never good for anybody you know all
right very important I appreciate you
making it I'm gonna let you go it does
sound like you're very busy there and up
to a lot of stuff so you get back to
that you sort listen to wrote you I
don't know if I don't know if you're
rubbing a banana on the phone or
something but it sounds very very odd
I'm the extent that I know of people to
promote that are doing good work I'll
talk about them you know the show mostly
is about political issues in topics so
that's what the focus is but if there
are specific people that I think are
worthy of a mention I will certainly
talk about them okay I'm gonna let you
go just cuz that something is up with
that connection I don't know if there's
maybe mice in your phone or something
like that